Hello and welcome to a combined effort by fire of learning and Mr Z to ask who
were the Celts,
what is their fascinating history and most of all,
what if their history had changed and the Celtic nation state had emerged in
ancient times?
This is part two of that video,
so be sure to head over to this series,
these channel to see part one the link to which will be in the description.
However,
if you have seen that video,
let's continue.
By the second century BC,
Rome had control over the Italian peninsula and was expanding around the
Mediterranean,
which inevitably brought them into closer contact and conflict with the counts
in southern France and northern Spain.
The Celts of Spain are more forgotten branch though archaeology and research
reveals a stronger presence and expected in places such as a studious and
Galicia,
the ladder region having been named after the [inaudible] tribe,
which as you may expect is related to the word call the Celts.
A variance would be among the first to fall to the Romans.
Apart from,
of course,
the Celts that were living in northern Italy as wrong controlled much of the
Iberian Peninsula by one 30 BC.
As time went on,
Roman power fuel,
that's continued expansion ever farther,
even into Lens,
which were mysterious and unknown.
The Roman who would move the empire is in northward into a terra incognita in
deal,
a huge blow to the Celts was none other than Julius Caesar from his stronghold
in northern Italy and southern France.
He moved to subdue Gaul and added it to the domains of the Roman republic.
At this time now,
the first century BC,
Rome could boast to be the greatest power in the world.
Though even people's it regarded as barbarians,
such as the Germans and Celts remained legitimate threats Cesar may have from
time to time exaggerated this threat to justify his expansion.
But many historians do agree that the Celts of gall could have challenged and
even potentially defeated Rome.
Caesar's gallic wars began in 58 BC and largely oh to Caesar's leadership
abilities.
He was able to defeat them as Caesars of do the whole area of what is now modern
day France.
However,
a Celtic leader named verse and get Eric's emerged to unite the tribes of gall
and expel the invaders.
He could very well have been successful.
However,
the gallic lack of unity and their tactical and effectiveness against the Roman
army would be their downfall and Caesar's victory was inevitable.
Following the battle of Alisia and 52 BC,
1 million kilts had died in this conflict and another million had been enslaved.
Rowan would expand further into Celtic territory.
As time went on a century or so later in 43 and Britain was invaded.
It is here again that we see many Celts join forces this time around the you're
60 and under the warrior Queen [inaudible] and that is here again that they were
almost victorious,
but in the final moments of the war,
Boca was killed and the Romans reverse the course of events and ended up
conquering much of the island,
the only heavily Celtic areas outside of the Roman Empire.
Now we're Scotland and Ireland with some tribes mixed into what the Romans
called Gare Manea criminy Celtic culture did not disappear.
However,
even under Roman occupation,
in fact,
in some areas as a mixed Romano Celtic culture,
he merged.
A good indicator of this is language.
There was cross influence in Rome's new provinces and we still today see romance
languages,
children of the Latin language like French and Galician with a little bit of
Celtic influence and Celtic languages with Latin influence such as well.
And this timeline,
Rome's focus had shifted from northward expansion to dominance of the south.
As far as the Roman populace was concerned,
the Celtic and federation was already Roman land,
so it only made sense to expand to lands that they didn't hold them in,
specifically for the up and coming Julius Caesar,
he would develop an admiration of Alexander the Great.
And upon encountering he statue of Alexander during one of his tours,
he would realize that at the age of 31 he was now at the age at which Alexander
had nearly conquered the known world.
And as an our timeline of wood shake,
something within him that would motivate out of the young Caesar,
a desire for conquest of Asia to Bush deep into the east,
topple the Parthian empire and spread.
Roman reached to the peaks of India and with Roman strength now strategically
concentrated down the African east coast as well as across the Mediterranean.
So did the opportunity present itself and naval raid and conquest of Southern
Arabia to establish a launch off point for see invasion of India and Persia
while land forces drawing upon Celtic recruits spearheaded and depart the end
lands,
the Celts becoming a force capable of fending off dramatic invasion,
serve as a buffer to protect room from barbarian invasion and the faulty
recruitment of dramatic soldiers who would ultimately turn on them.
Though this couldn't stop the same mistakes from being made in the eastern
campaigns by Julius Caesar as go,
Alysia becomes increasingly more independent from the Roman Empire.
So did the Roman government become increasingly concerned about the potential
threat the Celtic state may pose,
thus triggering a poorly orchestrate invasion of Galicia.
While Roman efforts were focused on the east,
this Roman defeat would set the tone for the next century of the client for the
empire North African lands would start fracturing away,
breaking off to be claimed by inland groups which Roman resources were exhausted
on Caesar's campaigns would have made him quite popular to some as he had
extended Roman influence further and further into Asia,
but back home it was becoming increasingly evident that these wars in the east
were siphoning away necessary resources and manpower that were needed
domestically.
Caesar's men would be cut off and left to their own devices without food,
water,
and gold.
The men would mute me under general and assassinate him leading eastern Roman
spoils to fracture as well.
Romans government would face increasing instability and even facing invasion by
the Celts and retaliation for rooms.
Attempts to subdue them ultimately leading the Roman Empire to crumble and take
on the new form in the following decades as the ACC,
Ian or a she and empire comprised of Greece,
the Balkans parts of Italy,
Anatolia and the North East African coast with some few scattered ports about
Europe,
Africa,
and Asia.
When the Roman Empire fell centuries later,
the power vacuum that was left was filled primarily by dramatic tribes like the
angles,
Saxons,
and francs,
which is partly why Celtic culture and society didn't make as much of a
resurgence in the post.
The Roman world,
the Romano Celts who were living in galled were assimilated into Frankish
society and became the French.
The only exception to this is Brittany,
which retains its Celtic heritage today,
although the bretons are not descendants of the original French calls,
they are descendants of British Coutts who migrated to the region later on.
Famous taken over by the dramatic Visigoths and sweaty peoples in England.
A similar process occurred when the Romano Britain's were overtaken by the
dramatic Anglo Saxons.
Though many coats flood westward to form the Modern Nation of Wales and the
territory of Cornwall,
and as I said,
migrated to France and one later become the territory of Brittany.
Each of these places tracing their heritage back to their Celtic Britain,
heritage Scotland,
Ireland,
and the Isle of Man who had effectively retained independence later joined
whales,
Brittany and Cornwall to become the six Celtic nations of the modern day.
Although some would include Galicia and the studios in Spain making it arguably
eight Celtic nations for much of history.
There are Celtic identity was suppressed or at times even lost.
It would not completely disappear however,
and there were independent Celtic nations for much of European history.
However,
in the 16th and 17th centuries,
Brittany was absorbed into France.
I,
Berrien county culture had already been absorbed in the fighting between the
Germanic tribes,
the invading Muslims and the other ethnic groups of Spain and the other Celtic
nations came under the rule of the English crown becoming Britain.
Yet Celtic identity and heritage would begin a resurgence in the 18th century or
so.
And in a modern day,
their identity is in some ways perhaps the strongest.
It's been in centuries.
Yet in other ways,
it may be the weakest,
the only truly independent Celtic nation is the Republic of Ireland.
And where are the six Celtic nations themselves have today in estimated
collective population of around 20 million people.
Only around 1 million can speak at Celtic language fluently.
Although there are accounts living in north and South America and Oceania who
can speak the languages as well.
Most of the other accounts such as those native to Spain or those who immigrated
to the United States do not retain a linguistic heritage.
Only being ethnically Caltech,
ancient Celtic history was changed by a few decisive moments.
But if any of those moments had gone differently,
things could have been drastically altered.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think the Germanic tribes would be a good place to start looking because of
the effect that had on the later Roman empire.
You have to wonder if it has a similar effect on the Celtic nation if they to
start migrating and pushing against the boundaries and then,
yeah,
precisely.
The Celts would have ancestral animosity toward the,
uh,
towards the Germanic tribes because they were the ones primarily feuding than
they would have been pushed out.
They're able to fend them off in this timeline and develop more of a rivalry
with them.
The question is what the dramatic tribes advanced a little faster,
uh,
and what the dramatic tribes pose as much of a threat to Galicia as they had to
Rome.
Oh,
I could see them like mimicking the couch because that was similar to tribal
structure.
There you go about unifying their own type of country in the same way.
The Celts side,
right?
They wouldn't have the benefits that Rome had given the Celts,
but you could certainly see them observing and copying as well as you.
You might have some desserts from the Celtic state going over there and trying
to organize something themselves.
Uh,
not to mention Roman soldiers who would be in that region when Rome fell and,
or,
uh,
again,
a dessert is from the Roman army who moved up that way.
This timeline,
Galicia invades northern Rome and captures portions of it in retaliation.
So some northern Romans could have fled into the dramatic,
a dramatic region and attempted to unify it to create a new rival state to the
Celts.
It could be something of a Rome 2.0 but built with dramatic stuck or it could
just be an independent,
uh,
dramatic state that forms out of a purely without Roman influence.
Which ones you think is more likely because again,
you do have the deserters from,
uh,
from the eastern Roman Empire and,
and you have the Romans who would flee from,
uh,
northern Rome when Felicia invaded
like us.
Germany in the time was more cutoff from interaction and Roman,
I guess what would be the coalition empire here?
So probably something that would be more
independent.
Yeah.
You also got to consider that they don't want be far less Roman influence there
and thus they would speak different languages.
Communication would just be near impossible between these two.
So through limitations and dramatic tribes try to create a state mimicking the
Celts.
Now,
historically,
the,
uh,
the Germans were able to far out compete the Celts.
Cesar seem to have some concerns that the Celts will pose a greater threat to
Rome's future.
Then the Germans did.
Well,
can you expand on that a little bit?
Is that pretty much goes back to the fourth century BC.
When the cows were active in the call,
was very active in northern Italy in second city of room.
Uh,
they were closer to Rome.
They had more interactions with them.
They were at times,
some of the tribes were friends with the Carthaginians saw.
There was kind of a big word,
more of a threat to Romy because of proximity and past history.
But there is also a vendetta,
I guess a sense of getting revenge,
right?
There's not necessarily a,
a,
a tactical or technological superiority of the Celts over the dramatic tribes.
Right?
Those,
the Germans out competing the Celts might be indicative that the Germans had the
tactical and technological superiority.
Can we see something,
perhaps a kin to France and,
uh,
pressures,
rivalry,
uh,
arise between
Galicia and the new dramatic state.
Whereas Germany just rapidly meant manages to modernize and melts,
rise then come back to Galicia and sort of drive them,
drive them westward.
I can see that
the geography,
like the Rhine river cause creates a natural boundary that's hard to cross and
lays a foundation for two to rise.
Right.
And you think the Rhine River would be a good spot to just set the border
between the two?
Yeah,
I could see out over time
Germans kind of pushed the Celtic nation back over the Rhine river and from
their separate nation states would arise.
What about the eastern border?
So we established the western border,
but now we also got to consider that the Slavs or uh,
the Slavs are still in that region.
The Germans,
because the kelsies had repelled them and push them more eastward,
had intermingled with the Slavs a little more,
but they perhaps in the form of better relations or perhaps they've developed a
rivalry,
but you do have them there and eventually you're going to have the huns and the
Mongols flooding in and thus the slabs games
get pushed westward even more.
Yeah,
I could see that creating a lot of tension in the whole area of Europe.
I don't know if that would lead to the Slavs mimicking the nation state.
Like the Kelton,
maybe the Germans would,
but I was thinking that the Slavic invasions that happened in the seventh
century,
so than the hands,
and then later on the Mongols,
we've got a lot of pressure on the,
uh,
the coalition state,
right?
Let's see it as sort of protected because again,
you have the dramatic tribes and below that you have the alternate Byzantine
Empire,
which is screen something of a block cake.
Alyssia is safely nestled away in western Europe.
The issue that could be posed in the future would be that of the Mayan
Caliphate,
which in this timeline probably wouldn't exist because Islam is far weaker,
just doesn't exist.
You might also see,
no,
not even that the Mongol hordes would most likely be stopped by Germany and the
alternate Byzantine Empire.
And that would really be,
they have a buffer that Galicia is very well protected.
And that might actually be a,
a bit of a downfall for the Celts because the Celts,
Vito only needs to face those two threats.
Those two threats would be faced up against all the on slot that's gonna be
going on in central Europe.
And Central,
you're going to become a real battle ground and thus will need to adapt to that
cause the Celts aren't facing any hardship.
They might begin to slack a little bit and become a little softer for something
which could prime them for a re conquest by the Byzantine Empire to re more of
the 10 Italian peninsula or maybe a,
the dramatic tribes pushing further westward.
Like I say that,
what do you see the,
uh,
the vikings to the vikings pushing into Ireland,
but Ireland and Scotland.
But just as in our timeline,
we,
they'd probably be repelled even more senescence.
They're more prepared and the matter of the dramatic state,
it would likely be something that came to the holy Roman Empire word be a bunch
of disunified.
It'd be a bunch of fairly autonomous tribes with maybe a hiking ruling them,
much like the confederation.
It's eight is a confederation of tribes.
Yeah.
Just looking at the map,
you can seek a list.
He has a very well protected by the Germanic tribes.
Uh,
we could see a primary dramatic nation forming along the borders of Galicia,
just out of necessity to repel any advancement by the Celts and combat them.
So they'll just unify out and think of unified in necessity.
Again with,
uh,
with Galicia it's,
it's very well nestled away.
Its main competitors will likely be the Akkadian Empire and Germanic tribes row
and at that might soften it up,
but there's the expansion of Galicia.
If Germany,
if the Germanic tribes managed to unify into a state,
they would like to be able to hold off,
um,
at the Rhine river.
So when that perhaps would that opened the door for Galicia to expand into the
new world,
into Greenland or maybe North Africa,
ah,
glitzy as occupying all the major,
a colonial powers,
oh,
at least their territory.
And it's just a wide open a stretch for it.
It could go from Iberia and expand into South America.
They can go from,
uh,
directly from the British isles and expanded northward into Greenland or Canada
or from France.
It should be a fairly straight shoot to mid Canada or the US.
I can see that happening in later years.
I was the,
uh,
the nation stays in tact
and this time I was talking to them.
The worst.
I'm in the,
uh,
we're gaining the upper hand.
I'm a necessity.
Yeah.
Neighborly and still spending extending into Iceland and Greenland and on their
own.
But I can see them going into North Africa and stop talking.
Like there's that incentive by owning Hispana.
We might not see Slavic expansion to the Balkans.
However,
that might remain a reco Roman in culture.
Do you think the state structure in Europe would be,
because clearly Galicia is something of a superstate,
it's an empire,
much like Rome,
but how long would go with CLS as an empire and what lands do you believe would
retain?
I could see a fragmenting a lot more as it deals with the stresses of the Norse
and the Germans and maybe a mag terrorism,
maybe it African youth invader.
The Celts Iberians themselves might,
might feel distinct enough to create their own country and thus Iberia could
break off that northern portion of a,
of the Italian peninsula might still consider itself Roman and revolts could
lead that to break off as well as Corsican Sardinia,
no,
I can see France and uh,
the British isles being retained as well as most of,
uh,
most of 'em.
What would be Switzerland in Austria since those,
since Switzerland is mostly,
yeah,
the Alps and you couldn't imagine,
I wouldn't imagine many people moving in there to invade a,
we could see,
I could see the German tribes easily fragmenting and then reforming it to a few,
a few different times in two different states.
And the acne and empire might be able to create a greater Greece.
I could see the Greek and Anatolian portions of the and empire,
uh,
remaining a state.
No,
I feel that the Italian portion of it might be break off.
This might,
uh,
that might,
um,
might or may not include Cecily.
CECILY could be more influenced by the Afghan empire and become a portion of it.
But the Italian,
yeah.
Peninsula itself would likely break off and become its own independent state.
And,
uh,
the Parthian Empire,
I could see it holding a good dominion over much of much ancestral Persian land,
but I not sure it would be able to retain a hefty hold over landholdings in
southern Arabia.
He'll remind me.
I was going to mention the Aki and empire here doesn't look as much like Rome as
the Roman Empire looks more like a,
a Greek empire,
a middleweight what controls Italy.
Definitely see Roman,
the rest of the Greek islands kind of splitting.
Right.
Overall,
I think that's a,
a pretty solid scenario.
I'm glad.
I'm glad we worked together and I liked the way the whole thing came together.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Me Too.
Okay,
well thank you all for watching,
uh,
promoted for more videos like this.
Be sure to check out both of our channels.
This is the MR Z and fire of learning.
See you next time.
Shooting Star right there.